WERE MISSING FROM THE LINEUP
ESPECIALLY THE LAST BIT OF
SCRATCH FOR STEVEN STAMKOS,  IN
OWN ZONE, AND THEY AND THAT SHO
INTO THE CORNER, AND IS PICKED
UP AND SHIPPED OUT BY KILLORN.R
TOWARDS THE NET, THERE. TOWARD
STEERED WILL
BE AGAIN.
GREAT TWO WAY CENTERMAN, REALLY
GOOD ON THE FA, AND CONTINUES O
FINALLY GETS VIRTRTTUESDAY, TO
BIRTH OF HIS SON, CHASE.ONE, AN
>> Dave: TUESDAY PROVE ANYTHING
IT'S THAT ST. LOUIS KNOWS HOW
TO PUSH BACK.
LIGHTNING, JOHN COOPER SAIDTHE
THAT PASS UP AHEAD, HERE IT
IT
BACK,REILLY, THE SHOT, AND
HED BRANDON
MIGHT'VE HAD A FREE ONE.
>> Brian: A FACE-OFF WIN, THEY
20 IS GOING TO GET BEHIND.
THE PUCK WILL COME FROM THE DOW
AND FIRES THE SHOT.
AND FORCED TO THIS POWER
KNEW
WALLMAN WAS UNDER PRESSURE, ON
WAY HE DID.
>> Dave: SIT BACK IN WAITING TH
VICTOR HEDMNEARSIDE.
>> Brian: THAT'S WHEN YOU HAVE
AN ADVANTAGE, AY.
TRYING TO GET, AND HE GOT JUST
ENOUGH OF THAT.KNOW WHAT IT HIT
STAYED IN THE ZONE AND LED TO
ALL THIS
O'REILLY, LOST THE HANDLE TO
RADISH.
AND HE'S HAD ALL IN
NEARSIDE, NOW, FOR BELLEMARE.
EIGHT ON THE LINE TO THE MIDDLE
TALK ABOUT MONO AMATO,